the crawler vs hisoka rematch is on its
way the highly Man part driven battle
clown is on a collision course with Mr
spider Commander himself with both of
them most recently being spotted on tier
3 of the black whale 1. so just how
exactly is this going to play out
crowler uses bungee gum against hisoka
look I don't know if I should be
admitting this but I got genuine chills
from reading that comment the idea of
crawla obtaining bungee gum in a method
best described as somehow would be an
incredibly crazy twist forcing hisoka to
think even harder than usual to fight
his way out of everything with texture
surprise alone or whatever potentially
new post-mortem powers he has but I just
really like the idea of crolo very
calmly and collectedly saying the words
bungee gum and then he soak his eyes
lighting up in Terror as he realizes
what has happened hisoku would probably
start to distrust his eyes so much that
he would need to whip out his trusty
pair of glasses which he does have
thanks to the hunter hunter
collaboration with zoth where apparently
both hisoka and crawler have their own
specially designed frames hisoka
revoking some very grandfather energy
whilst scroller looks like an
amalgamation of every High School nerd
it's those thick thick with so many seas
frames that do it but I suppose the big
question is would it even be possible
for crolo to steal hisoka's ability and
this may or may not be a controversial
opinion but I actually don't think that
hisoku would be wildly difficult to
steal from at least not compared to
professional trained Nan assassins like
Xeno and Silva their lifestyle is almost
a direct counter to the conditions of
skill Hunter always being careful and
never producing words out loud unless
absolutely necessary hisoka however is a
completely different beast fighting for
him is pleasurable he takes a lot of
time to tease and I suppose whatever the
combat equivalent of like fluffing his
opponent is so looking at the conditions
for skill Hunter I think that most of
them are met fairly easily one crawler
needs to see bungee gum that's not a
problem because this man has seen so
much gum in his life that he is
practically an honorary dentist hisoka
makes no attempt to hide bungee gum
while that's not true he does sometimes
but often he hides bungee gum by
distracting opponents with other
applications of Bungee Gum as for the
second condition crolo needs to ask
kisoka a question about nen and have
hisoka actually answer it with someone
like Xeno there is no chance whatsoever
of getting an answer however with hisoka
he is significantly more likely to play
along the simple question like I don't
know what does bungee gum contain the
properties of and hisoka hearing that he
would not be able to help himself he
would feel the need to answer if only
for the meme alone that or he would
answer but he would lie to crawler and
that's something I've often wondered
about skill Hunter this particular
condition doesn't specify whether or not
the opponent has to answer crawler's
question truthfully taking it as
literally worded it implies that the
target just needs to engage with the
question so crawler could say something
like hey hisoka mate what are the
properties of Bungee gun to which hisoka
could respond with oh nice of you to ask
it contains the properties of my raging
clown phallus and you know what else
contains those same properties your
mother last night that's right crolo I
bungee gummed your mother
he could say exactly that and the
condition might still be fulfilled but
that's the thing about hisoka in general
yes he is an Undisputed and ingenious
but he's very playful and I think for
someone like crolo this would be a very
easy condition to meet the trickiest
part would be getting hisoka to touch
the cover of the book that would be
something he would be extremely wary of
and you know what actually brings up the
question of whether or not hisoka
actually knows how skill Hunter works
because I don't think that that's a
given I mean he definitely understands
the latter part of it the crowler can
use his stolen skills benaze to keep the
book open and there's a bookmark and
Stuff Etc hisoka knows that but does he
know the exact process required to put
the ability in the book in the first
place because skill Hunter has never
actually explained by anyone in the
series its conditions are specifically
told to the readers alone on the cover
page of chapter 123. in fact I would be
willing to bet that most of the Phantom
troop don't even know the exact core
mechanics of it and I want to say that I
think hisoka probably doesn't know even
so he's okra is smart enough to know
that one probably shouldn't touch
another man's Nan conjuration just
because it may just happen to be on
offer so crawler I would need to trick
him into it and again that's not out of
the question because hisoka is a
hand-hand fighter he just goes to give
Carlo a smack and then crawler goes aha
I block with my book and then bam
ability taken with the final condition
being that all of the above needs to be
completed within an hour and that's not
a problem at all because no fight
featuring these two is going to last
anywhere near that long the fight
battling will simply be too intense
given that it took crolo a year or two
to not defeat a far weaker hisoka with
all the cards stacked against him I
don't think it's a stretch to say that
hisoku wins this is definitely a big
problem for crawler that is not hisoka
this matchup is essentially the world's
greatest planner versus the world's
greatest improviser and strangely enough
improvised combat would usually favor
the one doing goal of the improvising
which is what this is going to be Prolo
previously took a whole year to plan out
his decimation of hisoka he controlled
everything to Perfection right down to
the location it was in no way a fair
fight with that said Carlo is a genius
and is definitely not to be counted out
in improvised battle punching the fact
that he survived a direct unplanned
conflict against silver result twice is
all the information we need to prove
that it's not just the planning though I
think that crolo is nion unbeatable when
he's in his perfect mental Zone and that
is not where he is right now crolo is
filled with all sorts of fiery emotions
that are very well known for impeding
all of the logical thinkings the deaths
of shall knock and cortopi or let's be
realistic here the death of shall knock
mainly has left crawlow in a very
vulnerable mental state whereas with
uvagin and pakunoda I think there was an
understanding an understanding that UVA
game did a dumb thing and so he got dumb
killed and buried in a hole and also an
understanding that Pocono sacrificed
herself in order to give the troop the
Insight that all of this is very much
their own fault for breeding the Beast
that is karapika in the first place
there's a certain level of respect in
both of those cases because one was
beaten by karapika's strength in the
Phantom troop they like strength
meanwhile the other was a victim of
being strategically outplayed by
karapika but with shanak and core topi
there is a lion that is being crossed
because they were completely defenseless
and the killing was also quite senseless
it was just done on a whim by hisoka
shanak's Death espec is very similar to
what happened with sarasa they were
alone defenseless brutally murdered for
entertainment and the corpse was left to
be discovered by their friends so this
has really hit crolo and Machi for that
matter a lot harder than pakunoda and
uvagindid this is despite the fact that
crolo had quite the close connection
with bakranoda so much so that there is
actually an official stage play called
Hunter Hunter a longing for pakunoda
except that title is spelled with her
officially romanized name so it's
actually called Hunter Hunter a longing
for Falcon whoever approved those names
like
they just took English letters seemingly
at random and thought yeah that probably
sounds like Pokemon I honestly can't
believe that this is real when I first
saw the poster I was like this is the
cover of a dojo the other problem for
crolo though is that due to the loss of
cortopian shanak he's also lost two of
the abilities that were integral to
defeating hisoka the first time again it
took him a whole year to find the
perfect combination of anti-hisoka
measures and now he needs to do the same
thing in a couple of weeks maybe a
couple of days perhaps even a matter of
hours and given that he may end up mixed
in with this whole Mafia War business
one really cool idea would be for
crawler to steal some hailing and
abilities because they are the perfect
victims they all have really interesting
and versatile Powers but all of them are
complete Nan amateurs they're not going
to be thinking about stuff like
conditions and restrictions in fact they
may not even have any concept of that
whatsoever I would bet like cash money
that the vast majority of them would
touch that book in a second just to do
it they're like oh book I touch and then
we would see crawler do what crawler
does best which is taking other people's
abilities and using them far better than
they ever could I bet cruel Roth using
crolo's officially romanized Data Book
name there I bet cruel Roth will have
another original heartsu like his
bookmark maybe like a book Podium he
conjures that he can set his book on to
free up his hands I love this idea I
love it a lot kind of like a priest
using an altar for their Bible
especially appropriate for crawler
because this dude is covered in so much
religion that I'm pretty sure
Michelangelo took inspiration from
crawler's backside to paint the Sistine
Chapel but it works because it provides
balance the advantage would be that
crolo can now use up to two abilities
with two hands like so and the price
would be that leaving the book on the
altar makes it significantly more
vulnerable to attack so crawler would
achieve a new freedom but only by
imposing a new and honestly pretty harsh
restriction but hey that is the Glorious
balance that is the nen system it would
make switching between abilities quite
annoying so it would probably need to be
conjured under the condition of Crawley
discovering two abilities that need to
be used in tandem with two hands
abilities that give him the versatility
to both deal with hisoka and defend the
podium I don't know what that is but I
do like the idea of adding that layer of
combat well who knows maybe crawler's
new hatsu could be a library card
allowing him to check out a third
ability from skill Hunter however it's
only for a very limited amount of time
maybe 60 seconds or something and if he
doesn't return the ability in time then
he will be hit with an overdue nen fine
how can this man make books and
libraries so damn exciting I predict
crowler will not fight hisoka alone
that's interesting because that's
exactly what he planned on doing in fact
that's what everyone planned on doing
when crawler said alright gang let's
split up and the first to kill hisoko
wins a prize but what followed has
generally just been the trip gradually
getting together and reforming the group
to the point where team thinks now wants
to meet back up with Franklin to
guarantee their safety in case some sort
of magic battle clown encounter I also
like that what hisoka said about crawler
during York new city is still true back
when he spoke to karapika he said that
crowler was always accompanied by two
true members and even though it wasn't
intentional that is exactly what's
happened here with shizuku and banolanov
asking to tag along and speaking of York
knew I was going through it the other
day and I saw something that made me do
a little bit of a think hisoka revealed
that he knew the powers of seven troop
members who have again she is a coup
crolo Machi Franklin parkunoda and
shanok and later on after that he would
come to learn cortopia's power as well
so eight and it's just interesting that
all of the Dead characters are in that
known pile meaning that banolinal feitan
Nobunaga thinks and kalato remain
completely unknown quantities to hisoka
although banolanov has said that his
heart suit doesn't stack up well against
bungee gum I also want to know how
hisoka personally power scales The Troop
because he is just as bad as every
Shonen anime fan out there during the
election arcisoka turned up to vote just
so that he could power scale the entire
Hunter Association assigning everyone a
number out of 100 so I would love to get
that insight into how he ranks The Troop
because he has a very solid system I
don't know what that system is but it
seems to work for him crowler will win
but will have lost all his comrades that
is so tragically depressing that I can
actually see it happening tragic because
crolo finally rids himself of the clown
curse but loses every everyone in the
process essentially repeating the sarasa
scenario many many times over in such a
short period of time to kind of make him
like a reverse Jesus instead of
sacrificing himself all of his disciples
end up being sacrificed and also making
a mockery of the Phantom troop
institution by cutting off all of the
spider's legs but leaving its head it
certainly is one of the hardest hitting
possible outcomes which would also be
tragic for the fan base because we would
lose hisoka but you know it could very
well be his time as much as I love him I
don't really know what purpose he would
have moving on to the Dark Continent and
this may very well be a great place to
wrap up his enigmatic existence as well
honestly I don't think it'll happen I
think it'll be a trademark Togashi
anti-climax you know usually I would
agree with the sentiment I mean I say
this so often that you're all probably
sick of hearing it but you can't treat
Hunter Hunter like a standard story with
your setups and your payoffs sometimes
they're set up without payoff and
sometimes there's payoff for that setup
it's just how Togashi writes however
when it comes to hisoka there's not a
lot of room for variation his goal is
just that painfully simple murder all of
the spider people full stop there is no
narrative twist that's going to change
his mind about that even if your new
style event Kurt and crawler would say
unable to use net again it's still his
time hisoka has patiently waited and
waited for this fruit to grow and now it
is time to harvest it ain't much but
it's honest work and crawler is no
different by the way his sole priority
in life right now is to kill murder that
their clown so for this to go any other
way someone would need to kill crawler
first or his soccer I guess but so long
as both of them remain alive this is
definitely going to happen however much
time that may take is irrelevant I mean
hisoka right now is potentially enjoying
himself on tier one no doubt bathing as
he always does in fact hisoka is engaged
in such a critical mass of bathing
throughout the series that the hunter
hunter mumbaga card game has no less
than six Quantum 6 variants featuring
hisoka in a state of undress engaging in
one of his no doubt five to six baths
per day it's also interesting because
like the rarer the cards get the larger
the quantity of hisoka bathing so the
rarer you get the more clothes you take
kicks off and if you want to see some
more of hisoka clothes or not then here
is another fantastic content video and
then click it